Republicans look like they have the
votes to end this impeachment trial the
World Health Organization declares a
global emergency on coronavirus and we
checked the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show today's Ben
Shapiro show is sponsored by Express and
VPN your online activity shouldn't be
public it belongs to you protect
yourself and express it VPN dot-com /
Ben already so we have reached the big
day today might be the day when finally
this whole impeachment thing that
started all the way back in October and
now is carried forward all the way to
the beginning of no of February it may
be over today the reason it may be over
today is because it appears that the
Republicans have the witnesses that have
the votes to prevent further witnesses
from testifying and say further
witnesses because all of the witness
testimony from the house was in fact
admitted as evidence in the Senate
impeachment trial so what you keep
hearing from the media which is that
there were no witnesses not technically
true there were witnesses and many of
the witnesses that were quote-unquote
called during the Clinton impeachment
was the same thing they were actually
interviewed by the DOJ or by the house
and then those transcripts were admitted
via video or via transcript to the to
the Senate impeachment trial so the idea
there been no witnesses is obviously not
true the question is why are there no
further witnesses and that question of
course was exacerbated by that supposed
bombshell that john bolton dropped in
which he suggested that the president
was pretty explicitly making clear that
he wanted withhold ukrainian aid in
exchange for particular investigations
from the Ukrainian government targeting
events back in 2016 and Joe Biden and
hunter Biden and CrowdStrike and all the
rest of it so there was a big question
coming up to Friday coming up said today
as to whether Republicans were going to
vote to admit additional witnesses and
as of this hour effectively there are a
few different options right the Senate
is supposed to convene about 1:00 p.m.
today East Coast time so that means that
there are a few different options that
are sort of on the table here option
number one is that the Senate votes not
to bring in further witnesses and then
this thing is over and by tonight the
Democrats have a few kind of holding
pattern things they can do they can they
can hold up the the vote on impeachment
for maybe 12 hours or so and by Saturday
morning this thing is over and Monday we
begin fresh with the Iowa caucuses and
the State of the Union address it's a
big week next week regardless of what
happens we
impeachment that is option number one
that one looks like the most probable at
this point then there's option number
two option number two is that there are
three Republicans who vote in favor of
further witnesses and this is where
things get kind of dicey because if you
get Mitt Romney and Susan Collins both
of hooba have come out for further
witnesses and they are joined by Lisa
Murkowski then you have a 50/50 split in
the Senate assuming that everybody on
the Democratic side shows up okay if you
have a 50/50 split normally in the
Senate the presiding officer breaks the
tie and normally the presiding officer
in any sort of Senate procedure would be
the Vice President of the United States
but in an impeachment trial the
presiding officer is Chief Justice John
Roberts so you could end up with the
unenviable scenario for Chief Justice
Roberts where he is the person who
actually has to make the decision as to
whether further witnesses are called
which throws him right in the center of
a massive controversy which by the way
is the place that Chief Justice Roberts
least likes to be if you know one thing
about Justice Roberts he really really
hates being the center of attention he
really wants to quote/unquote stand up
for institutional legitimacy he doesn't
like to inject himself in politics it's
the reason that he led Obamacare be
reclassified as a tax rather rather than
it's a fee the reason he did that is
because he specifically wanted to
quote-unquote not interject in the
legislative process so the the so making
John Roberts sort of the swing vote here
is just a disaster for everybody
involved except the Democrats cuz they
win either way if robert says no
witnesses then the Democrats you say cuz
he's a Republican appointee
and if he says I'm not gonna weigh in on
this so it dies and I said cuz he's a
Republican appointee and if he votes in
favor of more witnesses then Republicans
gon attack against a guy who's appointed
by George W Bush so Democrats in that
scenario don't really have a losing
situation and then there's the most
unlikely scenario at this point and that
is that somehow the Democrats do pry
away for votes for additional witnesses
and we hear from additional witnesses
over the next couple of weeks now as
I've been saying for a while I'm not
sure that the smartest strategic play
long term here is to go with no
witnesses like I hear the argument the
argument is let's just get this thing
over with it's a charade
anyway if the Democrats want to reopen
this thing in the house they can if the
Democrats want to call john bolton in
the house they can they can vote from
beach when again tomorrow right which is
all true they can do that right they can
call john bolton next week they can have
john bolton testify they can wait for
the subpoenas to go through and then
they can bring another impeachment
charge six months from now but the
republican calc
elation is okay you've already taken
your shot if you take a shot at the King
you best not miss you missed it's over
right dad that is sort of logic number
one and there is some merit to it there
really is and then there is sort of
logic number two which is okay if they
shut down the witnesses and then two
weeks before the election john bolton
goes on a speaking tour talking about
all the stuff you would have said if
he'd been allowed to testify then that's
not gonna look good not only for Trump
trembling care I mean Trump is not
really vulnerable on this score but it
doesn't look great for a lot of the
purple state Republicans who voted
against bringing witnesses so it is a
not risk-free move to simply vote to
shut down the witnesses okay we'll give
you more of this story in just one
moment
because then we are moving forward on
the impeachment vote probably by
tomorrow if if all indicators as they
are currently hold first let me tell you
something about me you look at me DC
cowboy DC cowboy I don't see cowboy you
know there's a picture of me that's been
floating around online for years I was
in Texas and I bought a cowboy hat I'm
leaning up against a truck it's a Toyota
and and it's been mocked widely because
I am about as urban a human being as it
is possible to be I spend my entire life
growing up in big cities and I'll be
honest with you I do own a pair of
cowboy boots
but the problem is when I brought those
cowboy boots home they're you know the
ones that have like the stitching on
them and they're all kind of fancy and
my wife looked to me she said if you
ever wear those out of the house I will
murder you and then I said to her you
know what though I really love cowboy
stuff I really do like cowboy stuff you
have to know I'm a huge fan of westerns
and seem like every Western ever made
basically have I read Western novels
like the great American West is a
fantastic place so having a good pair of
boots that is subtle and then I can
actually wear out and not be embarrassed
it's like a person who is not a cowboy
would be great and this is why I'm so
excited about to Kovas Tacomas cowboy
boots are hand made with high quality
full grain leather by world-class boot
makers they're built to be comfortable
right out of the box for every occasion
at home in the office out on the town
they have tons of timeless style they're
really subtle okay so as somebody who
cannot get away with wearing like actual
full-scale stitched cowboy boots and all
this they have fashions that I can wear
out and not be embarrassed not only not
be embarrassed feel great I just pop my
jeans over the top of them and they
frankly they look just like you know
they'll just like patent leather shoes
or if I want to wear the boots just
normally they look like normal boots I
don't look ridiculous wearing around
those but not only do I not look
ridiculous I
feel like I've engaged in Americana they
look really great I mean these are great
looking boots so Kovas cuts out the
middleman they sell direct to you an
honest price that is truly amazing for
this level of quality it's a quality
boot like I've never worn that other
pair of boots again right to call this
is the only boots that I wear and it
looks great I mean listen feeling a
little bit Texas out here in in swanky
LA is pretty fantastic so do what I did
get yourself a pair of Tacomas cowboy
boots today at Toccoa us comms life man
you can get away with it too I promise
that's te Co VA s comm / mentaiko vests
comm / Ben these boots are great they're
really fantastic and they're not gonna
cost you a fortune they look great so
Kobus comm / Ben go check them out right
now okay so here's the way the vote is
gonna go Republican according to the
according to the Associated Press
Republican senator Lamar Alexander of
Tennessee declared late Thursday night
who will oppose calling more witnesses
in President Donald Trump's impeachment
trial all but dashing Democratic efforts
for more testimony and pushing the
Senate toward an imminent vote to acquit
the President and he put out a long
Twitter thread explaining why it was
that he was not going to vote for
additional witnesses and here's what he
said he said I worked with other
senators to make sure that we have the
right to ask for more documents and
witnesses but there is no need for more
evidence to prove something that has
already been proven and that does not
meet the US Constitution's high bar for
an impeachable offense okay so the point
he's making is the point I've been
saying that Trump teams should be making
the whole time right which is yeah the
president engaged in a quid pro quo in
which he requested investigations in
exchange for military aid the question
is whether that is impeachable or not
given the fact that the United States
does have a legitimate interest in the
investigations at least some of those
investigations and given the fact that
the President of the United States was
engaging in what is generally understood
to be foreign policy now if you don't
like his foreign policy you have an
option to get rid of him that comes in
November they don't simply get to say
him exercising his general prerogatives
under under foreign policy even if their
product is you don't by the way I don't
like his policy here right I think that
holding back the Ukrainian military aid
was a foolish move I think that him
doing it in exchange for weird
conspiracy theories about CrowdStrike is
idiotic but that does not make it
impeachable as I've been saying right
Lamar Alexander said there's no more
need for more evidence to prove that the
president asked Ukraine to investigate
Joe Biden and his son hunter he said
this on television on October 3rd 2019
and during his 12 July 25th 2019
telephone call with the presidents of
Ukraine
no need for more evidence to conclude
the president withheld US aid at least
in part to pressure Ukraine to
investigate the Biden's the house
managers have proved this with what they
call a mountain of overwhelming evidence
there is no need to consider further the
frivolous second article of impeachment
that would remove the president for
asserting his constitutional prerogative
to protect confidential conversations
with his closest advisors was
inappropriate for the President to ask a
foreign leader to investigate his
political opponent and to withhold US
aid to encourage that investigation when
elected officials inappropriately
interfere with such investigations it
undermines the principle of equal
justice under the law but the
Constitution does not give the Senate
the power to remove the president from
office and ban him from this year's
ballot simply for actions that are
inappropriate the question then is
whether or not the president is not
whether the president did it but whether
the US Senate or the American people
should decide what to do about what he
did I believe that the Constitution
provides that the people should make
that decision in the presidential
election that begins in Iowa on Monday
the Senate has spent nine long days
considering this mountain of evidence
the arguments of the house managers and
the president's lawyers their answers to
Senators questions and the house record
even if the house charges were true they
do not meet the Constitution's treason
bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors standard for an impeachable
offense the framers believe that there
should never ever be a partisan
impeachment that is why the Constitution
requires a two-thirds vote of the Senate
for conviction yet not one house
Republican voted for these articles if
this shallow hurried wholly partisan
impeachment were to succeed it would rip
the country apart pouring gasoline on
the fire of cultural divisions that
already exists it would create a weapon
of Perpetual impeachment to be used
against future presidents whenever the
House of Representatives is of a
different political party our founding
documents provide for duly elected
presidents who serve with the consent of
the governed not at the pleasure of the
United States Congress let the people
decide okay so what he is saying here is
wholly true I will say this with one
caveat which is this doesn't answer why
you would vote against the witnesses
right if the answer is why you'd vote
against the impeachment it answers why
you would not vote to impeach the
president but the Democrats are saying
okay well what if John Bolton were to
come forward and testify that the
president told him he was going after
Joe Biden because he was afraid of him
2020 would that change your math at all
right that that sort of and Republicans
are pushing back saying well you guys
could have called them in the house at
any time but it doesn't really answer
the question and that's my fear right
not that John Bolton would actually say
that but that the House Democrats and
the and Democrats generally and the
media claiming that this is a cover-up
whether that has any impact on some of
those swing state senators I mean Adam
Schiff was playing this up to the hill
yesterday he
he was basically begging the Republicans
let's limit the witness subpoenas to one
week you keep saying it's gonna drag out
for weeks how about this we'll make a
deal
witness will let limit the witness
subpoenas to one week and then we'll be
done here is Adam Schiff trying to make
this argument yesterday I will make an
offer to opposing counsel who have said
that this will stretch on indefinitely
if you decide have a single witness let
cabin the depositions to one week in the
Clinton trial there was one week of
depositions and you know what the Senate
did during that week they did the
business of the Senate the Senate went
back to its ordinary legislative
business while the depositions were
being conducted you want the Clinton
model let's use the Clinton model let's
take a week let's take a week to have a
fair trial
okay the Republican comeback came
courtesy of representative Steve Scalise
the house the house Minority Whip the
from Louisiana he says listen why
exactly the shift even need more
witnesses I mean they keep saying he's
made the case okay this is this is true
right it is true the Democrats keep
saying we have the case for impeachment
so why do they need more witnesses
that's again that is a good point right
the point that Democrats made their
strongest case the case is not good and
so we're not gonna make their case for
them like if they want to take this up
in the house again they can take this up
in the house again that's the houses job
is not about argument from Scalise Jay
Sekulow I thought had the mic dropped
moment when he looked over an atom shift
sitting there on the Senate floor today
and he said over 30 times you said that
you made your case and literally you
know looking over at chef and shift said
yes
so if Schiff made his case why do you
need more witnesses especially when
Sekulow pointed out oh and by the way
we'll call the witness whistleblower
will call Adam Schiff we'll call joanne
hunter Biden you know is this gonna go
on and on for months or we all know the
president didn't commit a crime
okay so senator Susan Collins for her
part she came out at basically the same
time as Lamar Alexander and she said
that she would vote in favor of more
witnesses this makes sense on a
political level the reason it makes
sense on a political level if she is
voting in favor of witnesses presumably
knowing that Lamar Alexander was gonna
vote against witnesses so the vote has
no actual impact right she gets to say
to her constituents I called for more
witnesses what are you blaming me for at
the same time her vote was not
swing vote to ensure that the witnesses
actually happened she put out a
statement saying we have heard the cases
argued in the questions answered in
keeping with the model used for the
impeachment trial of President Clinton
at this point senators are able to make
an informed judgment about what is in
dispute and what is important to the
underlying issues I worked with
colleagues to ensure the schedule for
the trial included a guaranteed up or
down vote on whether or not to call
witnesses
I believe hearing from certain witnesses
would give each side the opportunity to
more fully and fairly make their case
resolve any ambiguities and provide
additional clarity therefore I will vote
in support of the motions without
witnesses and documents to be subpoenaed
if this motion passes I believe that the
most sensible way to proceed would be
for the house managers and the
president's attorneys to attempt to
agree on a limited and equal number of
witnesses for each side if they can't
agree then the Senate should choose the
number of witnesses as this does give
Susan Collins some political cover for
her main race but obviously it has no
impact if the Republicans have 51 votes
not to call more witnesses at this point
and you know again I think the media are
gonna blame the Republicans but the fact
is that if the Democrats have done their
job in the house none of this would've
been an issue in the first place right I
mean if they just waited to adjudicate
the Bolton subpoena if they'd waited to
adjudicate the documentary subpoenas
from the executive branch none of this
would have been a problem in the first
place so it's easy for them to blame the
Republicans and sure you can make the
case that Republicans ought to be
allowing witnesses but let's just be
real about this during Adler and Adam
Schiff showed up
with nothing but their bleep in their
hands here they did not have the case
they did not have the case okay and
because they did not have the case they
were then calling on the Senate to fill
in the gaps in their own case and let's
assume for a second that john bolton had
not come out with this quote-unquote
bombshell a week before the end of this
thing then everybody would acknowledge
that there is no need to call additional
witnesses because who would those
additional witnesses be okay it was just
because bolton spoke up this became a
hot issue now the reason i've been
saying that maybe republicans should
consider additional witnesses is not
because i believe it would change the
outcome in fact i've said precisely the
reverse i don't think you changed the
outcome the only reason that i have
suggested that it might be a good idea
to allow the calling of additional
witnesses is because you want everything
out right now because you don't want it
all coming out later via another channel
and hurting the senators who voted
against allowing the witnesses in the
first place and you can see the media
already building up to this right Carl
Bernstein of Woodward and Bernstein Fame
he was on television last night and he
was suggesting it to cover up they have
covered up what the President of the
United States has done
in his Grievous action when they had the
ability to find out more and reach a
bipartisan as it were a decision if we
could hear from the witnesses if mr.
Bolton could come in and tell us is
there anything else there no maybe it
would be exonerating this is a cover-up
plain and simple okay it's not a
cover-up plain and simple because again
the house has the means at its disposal
to simply call Bolton so it's not a
cover-up when there is a branch and
independent branch of government that
has the ability to make all of this
happen like right now in the here and
now it's also not a cover-up because
frankly the Senate gets to decide its
own procedures right acting in
coordination with normal procedures
which is what this is Senate gets to
decide its own procedures you may not
like the procedures that's how the
process works that does not constitute a
cover-up a cover-up is where you do
something illegal in order to prevent
information from coming out and as the
Trump team and the GOP were pointing out
yesterday there was a political article
that came out during Thursday night's
proceedings about how former VP Joe
Biden actually argued against including
new witnesses during former President
Bill Clinton's impeachment trial and
that Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer agreed with him Trump attorney
patrick Philbin called it the Biden
doctrine and the Biden rule and and
suggested that five minutes ago the the
Democrats who were very much in favor of
barring witnesses now of course they've
flipped their positions of course the
same is true for a lot of the
Republicans with regard to Clinton
impeachment now in a second we'll get to
the Democratic reaction to all of this
because it's beginning to dawn on them
that this thing went nowhere
and that they don't have a lot coming
out of this right there they really that
barring again more of those other shoes
dropping that so many people are
predicting barring any of that the
Democrats really have nothing here and
you can see how desperate they are from
the proceedings yesterday and from what
they were saying about what impeachment
means generally we'll get to that in
just one second hey let's be real about
this you don't know what's coming
tomorrow you don't know what's coming
tomorrow I don't know it's coming
tomorrow is the president going to have
to face more witnesses or is he not
what's gonna happen in Iowa who the hell
knows is there gonna be an earthquake
out here in Los Angeles that you never
know at anybody this is why if you are
smart you have home insurance in fact in
many states it is in the law that you
have home insurance well if you need the
best home insurance possible policy
genius will compare your policy against
options from top insurers make sure that
you are getting the right home insurance
coverage at the best possible price they
have saved their customers an average of
six hundred ninety dollars per year
doing just that
policy genius finds you a better rate
than what you're currently paying
they'll do all the work to get you
switched over if you own a car policy
genius will compare your home and auto
policies across different insurers and
even mix-and-match to find you savings
as well so you never know what's
happening in life you don't know what's
happening next but this is why Insurance
exists to mitigate risk in the future do
it for your homes if your auto they also
have life insurance policies you've
heard me talk about that before be
responsible get insured check out policy
genius right now everybody gets the
future wrong get your insurance right
because that means that no matter what
happens at least you've made a bet go
check out policy genius.com and insure
yourself against future catastrophe over
a policy genius I'm get the best policy
it's competitive shopping you'll save
time you'll save money policy genius.com
ok so the democrats desperate to spin
this thing as a victory in some way are
now trying out more and more ridiculous
argument so nancy pelosi the Speaker of
the House who botched this thing from
beginning to end I mean truly botched it
truly and well botched it right she put
forward this impeachment without
actively knowing what was in it and that
pre committed her to a path where
impeachment had to take place and then
because the witnesses were not giving
them exactly what they wanted they just
sort of forced through a partisan vote
which gives Republicans the excuse to
say this thing is wholly partisan from
the outset which of course it was well
Nancy Pelosi is now faced with the
prospect of having brought an
impeachment that did not receive a
single Republican vote in favor of the
impeachment and not a single Republican
vote presumably in favor of conviction
yeah and now Nancy Pelosi is out there
trying to proclaim that she won she won
she won right she's insisting that she
won even though the game is over and she
lost here she is explaining
don't worry president Trump has never
acquitted no matter what he's not
acquitted no you're gonna she's gonna
have to explain how it is that after
you're acquitted by the Senate you're
not acquitted it's sort of like saying
that OJ Simpson was not acquitted I was
Simpson you can still say he's guilty
but OJ Simpson was in fact acquitted by
a jury okay the fact is that Donald
Trump will be acquitted that is the
thing that is going to happen but she's
claiming that his acquittal does not
matter it's not real why Nancy Pelosi
explained do you think that President
Trump will be chastened and understand
that he's got a Congress watching him or
will he be in
Boldin because the Senate will have
acquitted them well he will not be
acquitted you cannot be acquitted if you
don't have a trial and you don't have a
trial if you don't have witnesses and
documentation and and that um no that's
not how any of this works so a few
reasons why this is idiotic
number one the Senate procedures are
decided upon by the Senate that's in the
Constitution and the trial is at the
behest of the Senate and the procedures
are decided upon by the Senate and if
you're acquitted you are acquitted
that's number one number two Nancy
Pelosi is actually now making the case
she's now actually making the case that
Trump was never impeached not just not
acquitted not impeached because she's
making the case you cannot have a Senate
trial without witnesses right so that
doesn't count as a trial okay well what
if you have an impeachment without the
very witnesses that you are assuming are
necessary for the trial itself right so
if you are saying that the the trial
never took place because no witnesses
were called in the Senate well you
didn't call any of those same witnesses
in the house
so what exactly were you doing in the
house does that count as an impeachment
now like this is just attempting
desperately to grab on to any piece of
news and try and treat it as though she
has gotten a victory when she's pretty
clearly lost angus King the
quote-unquote independent from Maine he
is not independent in any way his
Democrat he says without witnesses he's
never acquitted this is gonna be the
Democratic talking point he's never been
acquitted guys don't trust your eyes in
your ears trust me doesn't matter what
the vote says he's never been acquitted
frankly from the president's point of
view if if this trial winds up in the
next 24-48 hours with no witnesses he
can he can say well I was acquitted but
he really can't say he was exonerated I
think they'll all would be always being
asterisk by this you know trial but no
witnesses I mean one of the senators
last night said you know we had a we had
a judge impeachment
about ten years ago there were 22
witnesses and we're having no witnesses
in the Senate it's never happened before
and the American people letters did they
want very okay again this is such a
ridiculous ridiculous contention that if
you don't have witnesses at the trial
yeah you know what else you normally
have it a trial a prosecution that
brings its case normally you have a
prosecution that brings its entire case
right if you were if you're in a normal
criminal trial and the prosecution
showed up they're like okay well we
don't actually have a crime we're
charging so we're not going to charge a
crime also we're not gonna bring
sufficient evidence and we insist that
the defense call our witnesses for us we
insist that you that effect like in no
way is they sent at trial comparable to
a criminal trial so suggesting that a
trial has not taken place because you
didn't get the witnesses that you want
that you were fully capable of calling
in the house is an absurdity on its face
but this is what the Democrats have been
relegated to because they lose okay they
lose this is over they lose speaking of
losers Elizabeth Warren tried to get in
a final shot here at Chief Justice John
Roberts she is just awful she's truly an
awful human being so Elizabeth Warren
was what they what they do over in the
Senate during the trial is they submit
their questions to John Roberts who sits
there and reads the questions out loud
like all of these people are contestants
on The Price is Right or something and
here is John Roberts reading Elizabeth
Warren's question which is designed to
quote/unquote humiliate John Roberts and
of course the left is like look at her
humiliating John Roberts yeah except you
know what's gonna happen after this is
over John Roberts is he can go back to
his life tenured seat on the Supreme
Court and get to wear that robe around
all day and Elizabeth Warren is going to
lose in Iowa and then she's gonna lose
in New Hampshire and then she's gonna
lose everywhere and she's gonna go back
to being an elderly senator from
Massachusetts that's what's gonna happen
after all of this so the humiliation
visited upon John Roberts nothing first
of all nothing can humiliate John
Roberts worse than his own judgment in
the obamacare case but beyond that like
truly this is this appear isle nonsense
from Senator Warren is for the house
managers at a time when large majorities
of Americans have lost faith in
government does the fact that the Chief
Justice is presiding over an impeachment
trial in which Republican senators have
thus far refused to allow witnesses or
evidence contribute to the loss of
legitimacy of the Chief Justice the
Supreme Court and
Constitution and then he just stares at
her he's like okay this is bullcrap like
you're gonna you're asking the house
managers how humiliated I am like what
absolute horse pucky serious nonsense
honestly I'm more interested in what
watch he's wearing there looks like an
iceberg a that he's got on his wrist
right there I'm gonna watch it guy so
and that's it that's a nice watch there
John Roberts I like what I'm seeing okay
so but this whole thing of course is
incredibly incredibly stupid and it is
now over and we know it's over and it's
just a question of where we go from here
well that does clear the decks for
president Trump to go hog-wild out there
and he is indeed going hog-wild
out there he held a big rally last night
in which he just blasted the Democrats
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about what happens if
you have an employee who just isn't
isn't cutting it I mean I don't mean to
single out anybody like you know like
Michael from IT or something let's say
that your entire job is literally to
make sure that all the technology in the
office works and then just one day you
shut down the server rack like at an
Internet company which is what we do and
just the server rack is down and boom
like the entire company is down and
let's say your entire job is making sure
that the server rack never goes down
well you know then you might be looking
at zip recruiter com then your employer
might be checking out might be putting a
job listing I'm just saying it could be
happening checking it out at zip
recruiter comm now if you want better
employees or let's say that you want to
keep Mike around but he needs a hand and
not shutting down the server rack well
then you might go check out zip
recruiter com2 they get you great
results because you post the job online
and then qualified employees come and
find you with the results like that it's
no wonder that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the very
first day every time you open up a job
application you're gonna get a mixed bag
you can it's like a bunch of people
coming back on it that great except if
you use zip recruiter they help filter
the candidates for you zip recruiter is
indeed the smartest way to hire seewhy
zip recruiter is effective for
businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free and our web address
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire that
is zip recruiter com slash Dai ly WI re
zip recruiter com
slash daily where go check them out
right now and make sure that your server
rack never gets shut down
zip recruit com slash daily wire ok so
president Trump gone hog-wild on the
stump this impeachment thing didn't go
particularly great for Democrats now
again I still think that there is a risk
out there
lurking in the distance that John Bolton
decides that he's going to talk about
Trump saying to him that he hates the
Biden's and that's what this is all
about or that Mick Mulvaney does in an
unfortunate interview or something like
that or a document leaks right this is
why I was suggesting maybe the
Republicans should just go forward clear
the decks of all of this and then move
on with their lives but whatever it is
it's over and now Donald Trump is out
there and he is he is on fire he was he
was very he was very jazzed up last
night as he was getting the news that
there would be no further witnesses and
this thing is basically over so this
makes two narrow escapes for the
president over the last three years we
had the mullah report which dragged on
for years at a time
witch hunt and then that went nowhere
and then he got to go out on the stump
and talk about how he'd been persecuted
which was fairly true and now he gets to
go out on the stump and talk about how
he's been persecuted by Democrats which
again is about three-quarters through I
only say three-quarters and not wholly
because he did make a boo-boo with this
whole Ukraine thing it was very stupid
but with all of that said the president
this is the president's favorite place
to be okay that he said this way back in
2016 it was one of his best and most
honest lines the president said a line
and a line and I whined until I win he
really felt like this is an actual line
that Trump used back in 2016 well this
is his favorite place to be right is
that he's been victimized by the media
true that he's been put upon by the
Democrats true and so here he is
blasting the Democrats and saying what
they really want is to make sure that
I'm not on the ballot right that's what
they really want by the way their pulls
out it shows that Republican voters are
more enthusiastic than Democrats
Democrats are nervous
Republicans are fired up which is a lot
what a lot of people learning Nancy
Pelosi about which is if you impeach
somebody and you take the shot and you
miss all you've done is fire up from
space which thinks that you are trying
to toss him off the ballot unfairly here
is Donald Trump saying the entire color
of this thing was to come after you
which is again true I just got a beat
can you believe these people I got a
beat
they impeach Trump the best trade deals
the strongest military took care of the
vets we got choice
we got accountability for the vets
accountability we got all these things
and they impeach the president no that's
not gonna work
watch just watch they want to nullify
you balance poison our democracy and
overthrow the entire system of
government that's not happening I can
tell you that okay so listen Trump is a
larger-than-life figure again they keep
taking shots in them and they keep
missing they keep stepping on rakes it's
a bad look for them and the rest of
their field is just garbage in 2020 and
this is the problem for the Democrats it
truly is and Elizabeth Warren has
completely lost her mind
I mean at this point she's gone
Elizabeth Warren cannot deal with the
fact that just a few months ago she was
the presumed nominee I mean back in
October she was the presumed nominee she
was leading in the national polling she
was leading in Iowa she was leading in
New Hampshire
she had the ground game she had the
organization and then she decided to try
and fill in the bare bones of Bernie
Sanders his idiotic ideology with actual
plans and people like oh wait that's
what that plan looks like when it's
implemented that sounds awful that
sounds like garbage and she started to
plummet in the polls and so now she's
gone right back to the Camilla Harris
well and she is pandering so hard I mean
she is pandering like a panda bear eaten
at a Chinese wildlife market I mean she
is just really going for it here's her
Elizabeth Warren pander a pandering hard
pandering harder starring Bruce Willis
I'm gonna have a Secretary of Education
that this young trans person interviews
on my behalf and only if this person
believes that our secretary or Secretary
of Education nominee is committed to
creating a welcoming environment a safe
environment and a full educational
curriculum for everyone well that person
actually be advanced to be Secretary of
Education
Pandor hard with a vengeance my god
credit to producer Mike on that call my
goodness look at look at that that is
just death and people are cheering whoo
we're gonna find somebody a child with
gender dysphoria and we're gonna have
that child that seven-year-old child
with gender dysphoria
I am jazz we're gonna have that child
interview the prospective Secretary of
Education to tell us what national
policy should be with regard to locker
rooms and LGBTQ education senator
Elizabeth Warren now if she really wants
to do this honestly Elizabeth Warren
should what she hears what she should
announce senator Warren if she really
wants to win this thing this way she
needs to announce that her vice
presidential pick is going to be a trans
Native American half Native American
like her half Native American 1/4
Chinese 1/4 African American 1/8 latinx
disabled person with with vitiligo she
that person is gonna be her vice
president and then she promises that
because that person has the most than
the most knowledge of the of the world
affairs because that person is the most
sensitive to everybody's needs that she
will then resign as president that
person will become president right that
is the most woke thing that she could do
she could give up her white woman slot
to a minority she could do this she
could make this happen we can find the
most intersectional human being in
existence
she Kannamma Nate that person is her
vice president she can pledge that if
elected she will then resign and hand
over all power to the trans little
person so that they can so that they can
shape American policy hey this is I'm
sorry this is crazy look who she
appealing to who is the population like
oh my god now I'm voting for that now
that she's said that and and look at
look at her she's so enthused she's like
yeah yeah she got the hair shakin and
everything Wow
it's gonna be so sad when she loses and
then Ann Taylor Loft has to put all
those sweaters on it half off because
the market for the for the Elizabeth
Warren sweaters are just gone so that
that's exciting stuff meanwhile speaking
of delusional people Bert so it turns
out that Michael Bloomberg is going to
drop 100 million dollars on ads
attacking Donald Trump in just two
months according to The Drudge Report
the Drudge Report Bloomberg has already
spent more than 100 million bucks just
on the ads that attacked Trump and that
does not include the nearly 100 million
dollars more that that Bloomberg
spend on ads on his own behalf and it's
true I mean if you watch like any if you
watch YouTube or Hulu if you watch any
of these things that have ads on them
there will be an ad for Mike Bloomberg I
have personally seen three ads from
Michael Bloomberg okay and like that
that's amazing he is he's drying up the
market he is he's blowing out the market
it's pretty incredible meanwhile
national polling Sanders is now leading
a NBC Wall Street Journal a national
poll so Joe Biden is getting desperate
now and Joe Biden is starting to open up
the guns on Bernie Sanders saying he's a
Democrat Bernie Sanders is not a
Democrat yeah good luck with that the
entire pitch for Bernie Sanders that
he's not a Democrat this is like Jeb
Bush saying to Donald Trump I've been a
lifelong Republican you're not a
Republican the entire appeal of Donald
Trump is that he was running from
outside the party infrastructure and he
was shaking things up and bringing
something new
Biden speaking in Pella Iowa said I'm a
Democrat okay earlier he had told
reporters at Dairy Queen that the
contrast between himself and his top
rivals were quote unquote self-evident
he says he says he's not he says he's
not registered as a Democrat to the best
of my knowledge and Bernie has a
different view
so everybody is sort of is sort of going
at each other now but the fact is that
Biden is old Biden is decrepit Biden is
barely holding it together at this point
and so I do not think that he can hold
off Sanders I just don't I think that
Sanders gonna win Iowa I think that
Sanders gonna win New Hampshire again
the polling in Nevada is super slim that
is the next state and it's a caucus
state which which tends to favor Bernie
Sanders because caucus is all about
enthusiasm and turnout the only poll
taken in the last month with regard to
or the last three weeks with regard to
Nevada had Biden and Sanders dead even
the only state hears Evans saying this
for years ever since Rudy Giuliani set
up the quote-unquote Florida firewall in
2008 by the time you hit the firewall
was gone right any time you have a
candidate who sets up an electoral
firewall the firewall is breached every
single time Hillary was talking about
how she had the blue firewall in
Michigan and Wisconsin Pennsylvania boom
gone as soon as you have a candidate who
is talking about a firewall that
requires you know a full month of losing
in order to reach the firewall that
firewall is not going to exist so right
now Joe Biden's firewall is in South
Carolina because that's really the first
state where a significant percentage of
the vote is black I mean and he is
wildly
outpacing Bernie Sanders among black
voters but the latest polling in South
Carolina was only done on January 8th so
it hasn't captured anything that has
happened in the last three weeks
right now the betting markets have
Sanders is a fairly heavy favorite to be
the nominee for the Democratic Party
which is just unbelievable I mean it
truly is incredible now maybe the field
consolidates maybe Elizabeth Warren
drops out and maybe some of those votes
go to Joe Biden maybe Pete Budaj edge
drops out some of those votes go to Joe
Biden but by the way if Bert if
Elizabeth Warren drops out there's just
as good a shot that Elizabeth Warren's
voters move over to Bernie Sanders so
right now you got to be seeing this
geriatric communist as the guy who is
the greatest threat to take the
Democratic nomination and the reason I
call him a communist is because I would
like to see him before it before I start
just signing on to the idea that he is
Pro capitalism I'd like to hear him say
like a nice word about capitalism like
one would be good you know maybe revise
his support for various communist
regimes over the last 60 years
maybe explain why he was wrong in the
1970s to support nationalization of
every major industry in the United
States ranging from banks to the energy
industry like I would love to hear him
explain what change and if you say well
he's not calling for that stuff anymore
right so explain what changed explain
what changed her mind why you were wrong
why you're wrong in the first place
hasn't nobody ever asked him this stuff
but you know that that's food that's
where things stand right now with Bernie
and Bernie's got to momentum he does and
him being off the campaign trail is not
terrible for him it isn't because Joe
Biden is still wandering around
somewhere in Iowa trying to gather votes
this thing is wide open at this point
for my goodness geriatric socialist
versus Donald Trump my this is gonna be
what a year this will be gang we've
already had a a conflict in the Middle
East with Ron attacking American bases
we've already had the the President of
the United States impeached and we are
not even in February yet Wow wow you
thought 2019 was wild okay in just a
second we're gonna get to coronavirus
turns out folks don't eat bats I know
we'll get to that in just one second
first if you know anything about this
show you most likely heard me talk about
my art and support for the pro-life
cause well now it would be a great time
to subscribe it daily where talk on why
because we are giving a portion of our
subscriptions like just for today to
live action it's particularly
today because you know it just happened
to live action like literally in the
last few minutes
live action was just banned utterly from
tick tock they were banned from tick
tock for the great sin of promoting of
promoting a pro-life viewpoints they've
been and permanently removed live action
from their platform
well that's disgusting because social
media are cracking down on the pro-life
cause this is what they do routinely we
ourselves a daily where felt this every
time I speak about pro-life causes there
are people on the Left who try to push
our sponsors your membership helps keep
our cameras turned on our microphones
turned up even when the left pressures
our sponsors and that's why from now
until today like this just not just now
basically a portion of any daily
wire.com membership will be donated to
live action with promo code live action
to support awareness and education
around the world on the pro-life issue
so go check us out over a daily wired I
can't make her pull a voice heard we are
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation but before before
that it is I almost forgot it's the
glorious time of the week I want to give
a shout out to a daily wired subscriber
today that would be Travis on instagram
who understands the importance of having
the right equipment to get you through
the brutal Michigan winter in this
picture
Travis's elite beverage vessel is on a
job site nestled in a mound of dirt and
snow next to an excavator the caption
reads thanks for keeping my coffee warm
on these cold days real daily water
hashtag leftist here's tumblr hashtag
electrician well that we could help glad
you didn't major in liberal arts
thanks for the pic stay safe out there
and next week that could be you if you
subscribe so head on over to daily where
DICOM used that promo code live action
give a portion of what you're doing to
people who actually are pushing
something pretty spectacular go check us
out right now we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
you
meanwhile things are getting pretty
horrific surrounding this coronavirus
I've always one of these people who says
like don't panic until it's time to
panic because the time that you've
wasted worrying is never receivable you
don't get it back on the other end okay
but I will say that this is starting to
look not so great the State Department
is now telling Americans not to travel
to China at all they've issued a travel
advisory because of the public health
threat posed by coronavirus the w-h-o
has declared the corona virus outbreak a
global health emergency that declared
that on Thursday apparently apparently
there are now over 200 dead
there are over 9000 diagnoses of this
just by contrast the SARS virus I
believe over the course of an entire
year had about not had about 80 100
diagnoses so this thing is spreading a
lot faster than the SARS virus did I've
seen estimates that put the death rate
from this virus at around 2% the problem
is you don't actually know what the
rates are because the Chinese government
lies so we know what we have no idea how
many people are actually dead we have no
idea how many people have actually
obtained the virus and the biggest
problem with this virus is we don't
actually know how it is crossing him in
human is it liquid transmission right
the way that Ebola is for example or is
it aerial transmission which is a lot
scarier right like the flu like you
sneeze in a room and suddenly somebody
could get it or you breathe on something
and somebody can get it like that that
of course would be incredibly
frightening
the fact is that we do have human to
human transmission outside of China this
has happened in the United States when a
person who came back from China gave it
to her husband beyond that we also know
that the corona virus is is giving
people sort of secondary conditions a
lot of people apparently who are dying
are dying of various other sort of
conditions that are contingent upon the
the having of the corona virus in the
first place the biggest problem is of
course that they are now reporting that
you can you can get the the corona virus
you can actually get the corona virus
from somebody who's asymptomatic so
somebody's walking around they appear to
be perfectly healthy but they are a
carrier for the corona virus that makes
it nearly impossible to stop the
transmission and because you can't even
quarantine people you can't even you
don't know if they have it or if they
don't have it so once it spreads it's
gonna be very difficult to stop at this
at this point all of this is scary as
hell obviously but important to note
that in the United States there were
three point seven million diagnosis of
the flu just at the end of the year and
some three thousand people died of the
flu or conditions related to the flu
just the very end of last year so we're
not anywhere near that scale at this
point with that said this is not good
news this is this particular case in
which a person transmitted a
symptomatically it was described from
Germany and it could help resolve one of
the major unknowns about the virus as of
Thursday night it had infected nearly
ten thousand people in China alone and
killed 213 about a hundred more
infections have been reported in 18
other countries but no deaths now what
we have to know is why people died in
China did they die from lack of medical
care because China is a garbage country
run by a communist regime or did they
die because China cared for them and the
virus is just that much of a killer we
don't know any of that but good news our
media are on the case guys that they are
on the case and so I bring to you this
headline from CNN politics are you ready
for this so it's a picture of President
Trump and his coronavirus task force and
it is placed above a picture of Barack
Obama and his Ebola task force the
headline from CNN coronavirus task force
another example of trump
administration's lack of diversity I'm
not kidding you this is not is not
parody the CNN is complaining that the
people on the coronavirus task force are
not diverse enough because that's what I
want I mean I know that it's like oh god
we have a coronavirus world health
emergency get me three black guys and
Native American and a transgender little
person right now stat we need those
people in here right now that medical
degrees I don't care we need diversity
in this room dammit I don't need any
medical expertise those white doctors
you tell them to go straight to hell you
know what I need in this room
I need diversity in my coronavirus task
force I need RuPaul in here get RuPaul
here now now what is wrong with these
people what is wrong how is that even a
headline what is wrong with you CNN says
it's a statement that says predictable
as it is infuriating President Donald
Trump's administration lacks diversity
on Tuesday Trump tweeted photos of a
briefing he'd received on the new corona
virus spreading out of China we will
continue to monitor the ongoing
developments the president sent his post
we have the best experts anywhere in the
world
and they are on top of the 24/7 who are
these experts they're largely the same
sorts of white men and a couple women on
the sidelines who have dominated the
Trump administration from the very
beginning now nowhere in this article
does it actually explain which of these
people is not an expert it's just
assumed that because they're white they
can't be experts and white mmm by
contrast former Bharath former president
barack obama's circle of advisers in the
face of the 2014 Ebola outbreak in West
Africa was hardly so monochromatic
neither was it two abysmal in terms of
gender diversity this is the worst piece
ever written we have discovered it we
need to frame it we need to put it in
the Hall of Fame we need to gild it in
gold this is the worst piece ever
written over at CNN and yet as
unsurprising is the diversity issue and
the Trump era has become it's still
worth pointing out from time to time
especially as the country approaches the
2020 presidential election in earnest
that's partly because of the recent
photos of the best experts Telegraph the
kinds of people the administration seems
worthy of holding power what this person
was rapped on the head is a baby like
Brandon tensley I don't know what
happened to you sir please seek medical
attention ASAP from the diverse doctor
of your choice please you're you're hot
take is that the doctors who are trying
to solve the coronavirus problem are too
white that's that's you're hot take your
treat looking for some rip on Trump and
it's like oh well you know all these
doctors you got here talking about how
to stop a global pandemic he needs in
here right now they cast a Project
Runway get them in here right the hell
now like what okay speaking of stupid
media coverage so producer Colton made
me aware of this idiotic report I'm not
even sure this person is who is this
person Colton I had no clue who this guy
is
ASAP science okay and this person put
out a video we know that he is
supposedly intelligent because he's
wearing glasses that's that's pretty
much our only indicator and also because
he buttons the top button of his polo
shirt which even I a a tried-and-true
dork do not do and then in case he did a
video called coronavirus and racism now
here's the thing he's about to claim
that if you think that it's a bad idea
to eat a bat it's because your race
[Laughter]
our media uh the people on the left what
is wrong with you what is wrong with you
can they just say it's a bad idea to eat
a bowl of bat soup it's a bad idea like
I understand that you're all bat bleep
but can you just like really come on
okay let's listen to this idiot for a
second uh you live in Toronto where the
SARS virus got world-scale attention
that's because the only people who died
outside of Asia from that virus were in
Canada and most of them were in Toronto
with only 44 people dying in total in
Canada it had a huge impact on our city
we lost a lot of tourism we lost
millions of dollars but most importantly
we saw a lot of stigma and racism
towards Chinese people it's important
that we do not repeat those racist
notions that happen to your in Toronto
and we all need to be aware of this when
we talk about the current coronavirus on
our social media channels we've seen
lots of people saying things like this
always happens in China and relating it
a lot to the types of foods that Chinese
people eat but it's important to
remember that Western food practices are
what created mad cow disease and also
Western meat consumption has created a
big issue with antibiotic resistance
okay okay okay okay why is that
important to remember exactly like what
why uh it turns out that the last
several global pen that makes have come
from outside the West right we've had
Ebola which happened in Africa and then
we've had SARS which happened in China
and then we've had this which happened
in China I believe mirror's started in
China as well and that has nothing to do
with Chinese people being Chinese it has
to do with don't eat a freaking bat
I'm not the person by the way saying
don't need a freaking bat they'll be
like every scientist you know don't eat
bats gang you know it turns out that
domesticated animals you rip on American
meat consumption okay here's the thing
about domesticated animals typically
domesticated animals have had a lot of
disease bred out of them for years and
there may be other problems associated
with it but you know it's one prominence
not associated with that the wild zzs
you get from eating like a meerkat it
turns out that when you eat weird
animals bad crap can happen and listen I
am I'm person with one of the most
religiously restrictive diets on the
planet right I keep kosher which means
that we think pigs are exotic but like
if you think that you are going to like
take a chomp out of a cobra and this is
somehow a great idea and then it's
racist for me to say that and somehow
its race
for me to say please please do not go
into the forest and tear that lemur off
a tree and just take a chunk please
don't do that if that's racist what what
does that have to do with being Chinese
it has to do with cultural practices
that involve eating wild animals that by
the way the Chinese government is trying
to ban right now okay so if that's
racist
then why is the Chinese government
trying to ban it last I checked the
Chinese government is Chinese and filled
with Chinese people but apparently the
Chinese government is now racist against
Chinese people because they're saying
please don't eat the freakin bat-like
this is wild CNN reporting in western
market suppliers kanpai beef chicken
pork and if they're lucky perhaps some
duck or bison but the options in China
can be a bit more exotic vendors in
small city markets often sell wild
animals including rodents yak snakes
I even porcupines and experts say that
makes them far more dangerous the meat
could contain deadly pathogens like the
corona virus CNN racist racist if you
say that that guy should not eat a
porcupine it's cuz you hate the Chinese
breaking news right it's amazing racism
is everything now there's this whole
controversy yesterday over Pete Buddha
jej suggesting that America is driven by
Heartland values and people were like
Pete Buddha judges racist cuz when he
says Heartland values he means not black
people and so what the hell are you
talking about
it is hilarious to watch though by the
way as the media take the exact same
position on people who judge they took
on Ted Cruz remember when Ted Cruz
suggested that there's a difference
between quote-unquote New York values
and Heartland values and people like
he's saying cuz of Jews I was like no
it's cuz New York has different moral
values than people in Indiana they do
and also like who do you think the judge
is talking about typically the moral
values that people are talking about
when they say Heartland values very
often they have to do with values with
regard to sexual activity people just a
gay man who lives in Indiana so he ain't
talking about that he's talking about
like Heartland values means like hard
work you go out on a tractor like we all
know what he's talking about a Budweiser
commercial that's what he's talking
about
and the entire means no it's racist he
means not black no he doesn't cut it out
okay it's not racist to say don't eat
the freakin bat it's not racist to say
you know that rat crawling around in
your attic please do not pull it down
and roast it over a spit and take a
chomp it is not racist to say Heartland
values everybody
loosen up a little bit because you're
making the world
stupider place like each and every day
is stupider place Donald Trump's task
force is not diverse enough it's racist
to say you shouldn't take up like it's
racist to say now that if you go to the
LA Zoo and you take a walk around and
you see it as a dinner menu that maybe
this is a bad idea you know what didn't
you know it honestly maybe the
coronavirus should come for us all maybe
we've reached that point maybe it's just
time guys
maybe we should all sign up with policy
genius and let the coronavirus take us
just come on bring it we have reached
peak statistics over each peak stupidity
apparently there is no peak it's a
Sisyphean task every time we reach the
top of the stupid pile the boulder rolls
back down then we have to roll it right
back up again
there is no peak to the stupid pile
alrighty time for a quick thing that I
like and then a thing that I hate so
things that I like so I told you I was
watching like 1990s silly movies with my
wife and so my wife and I the other day
watched them the John Woo film face off
from 1997 this is one of the greatest
cheesy action flicks of all time first
of all Nicolas Cage was in every movie I
had just note that from 1992 to 2000
Nicolas Cage was in every single movie
playing Nicolas Cage he's the exact same
person and face off that he is in the
rock the difference is that in the rock
he plays like a chemist he plays a
scientist and in faceoff he plays an
international criminal who's crazy and
they're exactly the same person which is
pretty wild right
he's also the same person in raising
cane so literally the same person steals
a baby also performs chemistry
experiments and also is an international
fugitive so just things to know about
Nicolas Cage so this is truly just a
wonderful example of horrible overacting
it's John Travolta and Nicolas Cage
there what it would actually happen
during this movie this movie is they had
to bring in new scenery for them to chew
because they actually ran out of scenery
it turns out the Adrienne's hire they
chewed the scenery so badly they mangled
it they had to bring in new scenery the
movies great it's it's horrible and
great at the same time there's a little
bit of the trailer for face-off
[Music]
yeah slow motion man this is the 1990s
explosions slow motion people falling
off speedboats Nicolas Cage and John
Travolta looking at each other yeah he's
also in Conair I'm just gonna point that
out like Nicolas Cage into every single
movie so the whole premise of the film
is that people can switch faces and so
John Travolta in order to stop Nicolas
Cage has to become Nicolas Cage and thus
nicola and then Nicolas Cage finds out
that this is what's been happening if he
becomes John Travolta and it's just
since John Travolta acting like Nicolas
Cage and Nicolas Cage acting like John
Travolta which is to say both of them
just overacting and it's phenomenal it's
phenomenal so go check out if you run a
dumb movie this weekend go check out
face-off it is fantastically dumb and
also a fantastically enjoyable you know
what it's been it's been a bit of a week
here so I think that we are going to
skip the things that I hate today
and we'll leave you on a high note
because let's be real you can go watch
face off and worry about the coronavirus
this weekend just try to stay indoors
please try not to eat the household pets
if you can avoid it like if you just
don't eat your cat okay like that's not
a racist thing okay really like just
make sure that whatever you eat is safe
enough that you would have a child eat
it don't cut any wildlife markets over
the weekend that's not anti Chinese it
just means don't go please please do not
go to the nearest pound and find the
Wildlife Center and then just take the
tarantula and take a bite out like
please just don't do that okay I've just
a please we'll be back here next week
presumably when we come back impeachment
will be over so we'll give you all the
updates then and then we will be heading
into Iowa which happens on Monday right
Monday is the Iowa caucuses and the
State of the Union is Tuesday Wow
lot going on so make sure the rest up
because next week it's gonna be a barn
burner I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel
Whitehouse new technical producer Austin
Stephens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by Mike foramina hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 on the Matt
Walsh show we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation
[Music]
you